in germany not as an
immigration country people do
n't do it because they think germany
is nicer or in europe it's
great but fleeing for a
specific reason has changed our country the
way i actually don't
feel comfortable anymore that's a german ideal
someone who
somebody who is blond is on time that we women
key in hand go to the car at
night that was before 2015
[music]
at a political
station
[music]
my name is thorsten pollfuss and i
think the immigration policy
has to be changed because like this  it
can't stay hey i
'm jenny and i see migration and
immigration as an enrichment for our
society yes or no merkel's
decision in 2015 not to close the borders
i personally
think it's right i think the borders should have been
closed because it creates a
pull that
we  Yes, also saw many more
people than
Germans  wanted to have chland at all that
has changed our country in a way that i didn’t
really know anymore
i didn’t feel the pull so much
and i don’t know why
i shouldn’t feel comfortable here
just because i’ve found a few more people
at home i think it is
right because the people
came here with reasons so they are
not social parasites or people who
just said so
germany is super nice i want
to stay here
these are people who came
here out of need fled across
several borders
countries their families tried
bringing me here so they put themselves in
danger why shouldn't we give these
people a place of refuge
[music]
thinks for the first time thinks it's good of
course when people are helped
and i don't want to stand there
as someone who is now against people  from
other countries will have am myself
with an f, so to speak  rough married they are
not what this country is and
that is okay but i
think certain things are simply being
misrepresented here yes because we could
help a lot more people we want to give
people this money if we organized the help differently if we organized the help differently
it's being distributed right
now i'm saying money we're
giving to the refugee aid ost in this
country we could help a lot more countries
if we organized the help differently
, namely on site in
the regions where do you say who sides
which absorb like nothing so
basically says the legal situation
you want to record and you can
theoretically only record people who
have come directly to our country, so to speak
details as has been said is across many
borders is already not possible according to and the legal situation
so we
are already sending a signal that  we adhere to
our own rules that we have given
ourselves, which we are not alone
against  just have but not at all within the eu
i just wanted to comment on
what you thorsten said that with which
we make our own rules rules not
kept it is very important for me
to make it clear at this point regardless of how you politically stand on it
it wasn't a breach of the law, but the eu
has certain rules that
are supposed to distribute refugees, but
at the same time they also have in these rules
that, of course, start more than they are
obliged to take in
and germany made
use of that
i would like to take two steps
back  at the beginning you said that you do
n't feel well anymore and i think
it's interesting that you don't feel well
to what extent has the
politics of the refugees affected your
personal life
i would just recommend
amazing places to take a walk through the görlitzer park
just like that  do they feel
better than they did ten years ago  or five
years ago before the complete crisis in the service
i personally not
[music]
or if you live in a completely normal environment let's
ask the women who,
like my daughter, just do
n't feel like using public transport anymore in the evening
she doesn't feel comfortable there yes nothing
doesn't and wasn't like that in the past yes and i
think a lot of people are bleeding so
i don't feel comfortable either when i'm out and
about on public transport in the evening
but that has nothing to do with the
fact that i feel overwhelmed  but
simply continue to drive many people with
me who are also drunk up to no
good so and
there is not only a certain group of
people who are responsible for
it but there are many people from
four nations also many very very
many organic Germans are also  It doesn't matter
where people come from and the
problem already existed ten years ago, even until it
wasn't addressed so
clearly or  r women couldn't name it well
or women weren't
even heard of yes or no germany is
a country of immigration and that's a good
thing anyway I see germany is
a country of immigration i
mean he didn't just start now
but signed contracts with him back then
italians in the
people from turkey or
greece who come here and support
this country
[music]
for me it's just an
enrichment when people come here
and in the long run
we need people like we
need workers like we do in
different  sectors as support
for diversity in any case i see
germany as an immigration country and
important that people come here like
germany not as an immigration country
immigration country i associate with
that that
a country to which people
immigrate also has the ability
and germany doesn't have that people
depending on the German  and
come wanting to become german i don't mean
wanting to have a german passport, of
course everyone would like to have that, but
i mean that people really
say i'm german now i would
like to become german i would like to live like the germans
and that
didn't happen yes  and life here
, germany, for example, is also not an
immigration country because we don’t have
the rules for immigration, but
the immigration countries let people
come who they need ready also
find questionable i think you should have
more trust in yourself could
first see under we
the legislation  does he make our country
in the federal parliament and in the federal council depending
on whether the sentences only have to be decided
by the federal parliament and the federal council and federal parliament
the
people i know from my own environment
from my own family they came
to this country because
they
find beautiful country and what are in this
la  And it's nice that we regulate units that
will give you the rule of law that
we see men and women as equal
and so on
and it's like that in germany
i would say it's mostly
yes i have a question for you thorsten
you're the craftsman and we can
actually see that we need a lot of people there
so it's
really unreasonable that we're here, for example
flooded people who are then
pushed away from the workbench that
's something then you're a man you do a lot
more and give people a
perspective so that you also have more
colleagues and less
stress at work don't you sing
that he's something  what you
really bring what so I think the
approach is wrong yes we have in
certain  areas too few
craftsmen immigration won't be the
reason why that will change yes because we
don't have any immigration yet that
we say we'll get people who have these
skills and i would like at the
moment part is the largest part of
immigration from  not poverty war
persecution or any other
things results that everyone does not
want will be perfectly acceptable yes
and also correct what
you mentioned these are of course a big
problem in Germany is that exactly those
people are deported who
perhaps still try the best
here  to integrate and to arrive here, so to speak,
yes, and want to advance this country here
[music]
and that the people who endanger us tell
me now
and they will live like
some
terrorists who are now openly
not showing because of it  now stab
a person at the christmas market
[music]
so i m  we say that we women only
go to the car at night with the key in our hands that was before 2015. there are
other reasons and not
migration
but i have another question and
that is that you are now simply you that
you are not comfortable  it feels like
i mean you can't
dismiss the fact
that some people feel the same way, then of
course you have to be listened to, but
don't you think that it doesn't depend on the
migration itself or on the
people  who come here to seek protection
but in politics, which
isolates people, regardless of whether you are
German or whether you come from somewhere else,
and i think that
leads to debates about envy, so
you don't think that it's more about
politics and not  to the
people who come to us so
all things that are done have of
course happened to take care of many factors
that is very clear
and i think off  he sure it will be like
that our country is safe and
i would take a much longer period of
time than say the time of the
federal republic so easily the last 200
years through enlightenment education and
so on has actually developed relatively
positively and it is natural
everything is not perfect yet, now also clear
in all areas, yes, but we are on
the right track, but now we are
confronted with a
crowd that has not yet internalized these values
[music]
yes or no, integration works
here in germany,
oh well
i can also lift both of them i
am i would do that too yes there is
no specific group or specific
person responsible for this
i think it is a
task for society as a whole
i also believe that the
structures for people who have immigrated
are
super super difficult  penetrate
are especially when you think about what
kind of status the people have  people who come here
are they allowed to work at all
or are they just vegetating because they enjoy
a certain protection
or a tolerance status or something like
that all the money that we invest in language courses
or other things what
happens to the people then they have to go
back
i think  Politicians have to
change a lot, but it's not just one person,
it has to be the
majority of society who do their best to
ensure that integration
succeeds, and how I don't have a
panacea there are so many
factors that play together,
both sides must be given the chance  it's possible that you can
also contribute and if the chance
isn't there in the first place due to structure
or laws, then it can't be
the residence status of certain
people so
precisely if it's not properly
regulated and the people
want to arrive here and do something
but can't do it that way  I think
that's why this debate is failing,
what is d  german and we and you who are
we and you were so i count for
example i have a 40 hour job in
the youth welfare office here in berlin which is super
hard is poorly paid nevertheless
i do a super super like and worth
but from the majority of society when
i  go for a walk in görlitzer park
rather counted with other people
or with a certain group of people that is
also named by the majority of society
so it upsets me
that certain people are told that
and the other man should
integrate that means integration than take off
my headscarf to start with
drinking beer or something that's super super
difficult
we've
already touched on a lot of topics here in the discussion and I
would just like to know from you two
if we have a consensus on certain things
we once addressed the area of
flight expulsion protection
people who, for example  flee from war
or be it asylum seeks protection that's the first thing for
me  no matter they need protection
you are there in consensus that we
take them in because they help and the other
side would be immigration so in the
system in the long run you are of the opinion
that we can do more i think
by the way we need more
immigration we even have  not so much immigration
when you look at the numbers but how do
you see what do we have to do
I don't know if we have a consensus on
that
but
I think some points are similar I see it
similar
to hikes definitely have to
be I've already done that  named because we
simply need workers here in
germany we don't want
everyone to do every job either it's
not okay that
immigrant people always do it or that it's
not always immigrant people
who should do it but they should
be allowed to develop as you do
if you come here and
also the people who are fleeing war want
it if they like to stay here
want
then should stay and
be allowed to develop exactly as you want the
consensus that i might see between the
two of us is that's right is
to help people in need i'm
definitely there but see if that really works in the
mechanisms is now
i would say definitely the wrong
way yes because you don't completely
ignore the fact that the
further people flee they go through more
countries they are of course
exposed to a lot more dangers help on the spot already on their
flight
[music]
[music  ]
and what has never been clear to me before is
why the
human being suffers from persecution, especially
in the Syrian region of Iraq or something
, why
does he not look for a country that is similar to him
here is your well-known fact that in Germany we
already have a specialist immigration law  which
came into force on March 1st
, 2020. Anyone who
can leave their degree cold can speak German  nn
can immigrate to germany legally
is yes or no to you so
first of all i know that
new laws will of course also be passed in the federal parliament
and how this
immigration law works but i don’t think that’s
the crucial point yes the
crucial point here is that i
rather  would favor that you
yourself most yourself then most you
yourself in the north sea partly that you
as a country have to set yourself up in such a way that
you don't need it but we'll
take it we'll take it because we'll take
the people in the country where  the
come here your good people gone is that
fair i think it's unfair if
you feel comfortable here then you can
stay here me too many who
come here learn what to go
back or go somewhere else and
that's no problem
we  we are now dealing with a situation
with a view to the climate crisis that
we will see in many decades or in just
a few decades  there will be talk of
the fact that several hundred million
people will
have to flee because they will
lose their livelihood there what is your
opinion so i assume
that you are
not willing to accept that
people are drowning in the mediterranean sea what is
the alternative  plus because politics
politics like
Germany helped to construct in
Europe led straight to it and there
is currently no signal that
that could change what is your
alternative what would be your suggestion
it is the same if we look at masonry
or now since  recently the
stories that were pushed back into the sea at the borders you have to imagine that they were
pushed into the sea
so it can't be that we
are discussing here that we
close the borders or that people
limit where they should they should be in the
camps  we were
pushed back into the open air or to the sea or
got bitten by the rats there  abbert what
what is the alternative i do
n't have a good answer to that either other than to say
let's take the people in and
create concepts of how they
can be good here can arrive well be able to
work well be able to process their trauma
and become a part of our
society  every person who dies
is of course one too
many at first that would be very clear and
if i had the perfect solution for
everything then i would maybe just
join a green party
or go to a party which i am not
i will say it like that but i
I think if you compare it a bit
more often and green because you
always work with pictures of
course it's really terrible when
people are pushed into the sea when
people die and so on and
so forth yes it's all clear but how many
people will be saved if they
would not have set out in the first place
because they would have known this
route is not feasible
are themselves  aware that it is super
dangerous i don't think anyone
in this world takes their child in
a boat and does it voluntarily and
swims to nowhere with the hope of
getting somewhere that i can be
the basis of the argument so
it's not that it just works
people don't do it because they
think or in germany it's
nicer or in europe it's great
but they flee for a
specific reason and then
what should you tell them where they were
killed because they
're a religious minority politically
persecuted what  anyway, it's
better to stay there,
so i'll share your
opinion with thorsten that we can't solve our specialist staff problem
through analyzes alone
and the second thing i have
absolute denials for is that you
say only the well-integrated ones, so to speak
, the terrorists
are allowed to be deported  so everyone stays if they
stay if they if they stay
outside  but then one of them had to be
in jail, so otherwise it sounds like
that on sunday than ever,
walking around freely and enjoying the beautiful weather here
and so on, so
i would want to completely separate them from
those who fled in the
im  and then i have to
contradict you very few very few
come to europe they
do exactly what you said they
should plan their own country then they
go to the neighboring countries and if it
is no longer possible then they
only flee further i have waited so long
I also thought for a bit
longer what does it actually mean to be
German I ca
n't answer the question well I don't know why
I
ask myself the question quite often if
if if always a distinction is made between
you and me or
with us then  i think to myself what is where
because the big difference people are always
looking for differences
people like me  are made into
objects so
[music]
i call myself german why do i
call myself german now
because i don't know anything else i grew up
here so
people who deny me being
german that's
[music] so
it's going to be really weird for me and
difficult why shouldn't i be
german or why should someone else be
german than me what is a
german ideal someone who is punctual
someone who is blonde
someone who is christ christian religious
or not religious at all so what what
is this picture what what designates as
we  is only used in these debates
for michel gives a relatively
simple answer and it applies to some
and it does not
necessarily only apply to organic Germans
but for me German is for
Germany in the heart and who
loves
this country and lives in this country and with  this
story and it's very old every
other country also has old stories
etc. is also a bit
ide  can ntify and knows and who feels value
for themselves
as let's say appreciate it as a
company
I can accept as a
full whole German and they wo
n't just do it on a piece of
paper so that would be for me but I
can no longer identify what
the story through cologne today is
yes but that even said there is what
we would say in the debate today
that is maybe it was what got me
thinking because the
other person understood so a
debate like the one we are having today is him
meant to let two total opinions
collide and
then to discuss it
that's why
i find it difficult to say yes
afterwards no idea that you
somehow go out there together and
say yes about it i'll think about it again now i
find it difficult for me
putting some of the things you said
into it, definitely so
it's clear that in such a short
time you can too  won't convince the other of his
opinion and
doesn't want the debate for weeks that he's
just to have suggestions to think
about and
i think
for myself as such i would say
we can just make
the world a bit
better for them too  people who are in need
and miserable but the path we are taking
now is, in my opinion,
wrong and cannot be financed i found
the debate between genius and thorsten
totally exciting because i was washing insane
sands the whole time and wanted
to argue with thorsten but it worked
at all  not so much and political
solutions but rather a feeling of
frustration fears i think the debate has
just shown what makes the issue of
migration politically complicated because
it is a very emotionally charged
issue and worries and hardships tors would like to have
addressed high crime
or even one  insecurity in
public transport
these are problems that exist  n
and I think the problem here is
, so to speak, the
conclusion that this has become a problem because of the
refugee crisis or because of
immigration,
just wrong, that means you have to take
the problems seriously without, so to speak
, serving certain population groups in the morning
and that
also the political challenge, which
bothered me a bit about the debate
and is also a bit
shocking that not
once has it been brought to the point
what is essential to the debate, namely
it is about racist stereotypes
and racist resentments
with which the debate is going
on the other hand,
i think there is a lot going on in germany to enable such
debates or exchanges in
order to perceive
emotions because only facts are i don't think this debate is enough to
somehow come to a solution
and i somehow found it totally
pleasant  en  n to listen and
to shut up myself and let it all work on
me i experience this
type of confrontation in my
everyday life but mostly it is on duty
as well as what i experienced there was for
that you can then really exchange ideas about something like that
on  at the end the
result can be i still know your opinion in a
completely different opinion but
i know your one now but i
think that's ok a democracy if it
runs decently on an equal footing again
today i'm a little bit
to shape it because on the  on the one hand
the discussion is totally interesting
just to hear both sides on
the other hand i'm still
a bit shocked because of course we
all have to take our fears seriously somewhere
and think about why people thorsten
just build up such great feelings and i believe something completely
also very important is the
differentiation between the forms of
immigration that we nac  h germany
has you have on the one hand the people in
need of protection who are fleeing from
war and persecution and they
have the right to asylum is a human right
it’s not abel and on the other hand
we have people who yes that
’s totally fine the better ones
are looking for a place to live in Germany and
we currently have too few opportunities for
them or they also have too few
options or no options
from a system, i.e. someone who has a
protection status, so to speak,
to change the system because
I still have too few options  I think
that what politics
has to do I thought it was great how
he never just argued and also
approached the situation very
toughly. I will definitely take home with me
that we as politicians have
to work on our
communication because why  migration is always presented
as saying something negative that
is home
thanks to
social media
[Mus  ik]
[music]